All right, welcome back. It's May 19th
and we're in the first of our series now
on chapter 3,
combining
learning and inference.
So I'll just begin with pulling up the
overall
concept net. And does anybody want to
give a comment or a note or any just
overview or summary on chapter 3?
Otherwise, we will look through some of
these core concepts, talk about how
chapter 3 picks up where two leaves off
and look at the first three sections of
three. Anyone want to just raise any
overall first point or any like summary
or anything?
Okay.
All right. So, in uh
page 49. Yeah, Fraser, go ahead.
>> Sorry, I was trying to find the the hand
button. I just wanted to mention uh
chapter 3 in a lot of ways is
essentially a recapitulation of chapter
2. Again, we're doing hidden state
inference again. But the big thing now
is that in chapter 2, we assumed that
the parameters were of our model were
learned, that they were fixed and good,
and all all we had to do was hidden
state inference, you know, and and we
did that and we saw how that went. In
chapter three, we're we're no longer
making that assumption. So, we're
saying, all right, we don't know what
the parameters are now of our model. So,
not only do we have to do hidden state
inference, but we have to infer what our
parameters are. and we're going to see
that this corresponds to a process of
learning. That's really the big kind of
you know jump or or or thing that is
unique to chapter 3. So just wanted to
mention that
yes that is exactly the theme. Um
even though all model updates
will be handled in a unified way like
from the program that you're running or
from the free energy based updating
eventually.
This chapter is um between the inference
only chapter 2 and the variational
methods that are going to come into play
in chapter 4. and it is separating out
these two time scales of inference. So
sometimes inference is just used broadly
to refer like computation or cognition
or process. It's like the whole thing is
a process of inference and that's kind
of the unified approach to treating
cognitive or systems phenomena as
inference.
If we're going to be a little bit more
precise with what inference is,
inference is like the fast real time
online work that a cognitive system
does. So in a linear regression
situation, it's like you already have
the mean and variance
um
you already have the mean and variance
of this regression and the slope and all
the parameters of the line. And then
it's like light intensity of eight comes
in. Boom. 2.5 is my prediction or vice
versa. So the line's already in place
and you're gonna be just kind of going
around the horn. And the learning which
is the slower time scale corresponds to
how do you from a batch or from a
sequence of observations fit the best
underlying model parameters. So in the
context of like a neural network or an
LLM inference is the fast feed forward
pass through which is just like from
this token turn the crank and then
everything goes a pass forward loop like
the run inference like using a local LLM
on your computer whereas the learning
corresponds to the training phase of a
neural network. So not just downloading
the final weights of the whole model and
then just turning the crank and running
it forward, but how do you reach those
model weights
and that is like orders of magnitude in
many cases more computation than the per
cycle fast inference. So, we're going to
call the fast inference process like the
trained model, like the trained linear
regression where you already have the
parameters and you're not interested
necessarily even in changing them.
You're just getting in an observation
and you're going to map it to some
latent state just like chapter 2. And
we're going to pull back and ask how did
we reach those regression parameters,
Mark?
So I just want to make sure I'm tracking
here. So So inference it it's it's fast.
Could you say that inference is is using
your model to make a prediction and then
could you say that uh learning is then
adjusting the parameters or updating the
model?
>> Yes. It's kind of like it's it's kind of
mton Bailey, you know, like in
argumentation where there's like a
broader and narrow claim because
sometimes a parameter in a broader sense
would refer to any variable stored in
your program.
But in a narrower sense, parameter
refers to just like the beta values and
the intercept values of the regression.
Whereas you'd be more likely to call
like the observation observation.
But in the broader sense, the
observation is still like a variable
stored in your program. So there is a
sense in which you could call that a
parameter. But in this narrower sense,
parameter refers to just the knobs and
the dials on the model to be trained.
And then inference is just like the
machine is calibrated, parameterized,
and now we're just going to take in an
observation and make a prediction, but
we're not going to update our mapping
for how observations go to latent
states. Andrew.
>> Well, yeah, it it's it's slightly re uh
reiterating some of what Daniel said,
but uh just as we saw in chapter 2 where
we didn't have any learning and we
didn't change any of these parameters,
um we were able to see how we could kind
of derive an estimate of X the state
using Y, your observation or your
sample. And so here in chapter 3, we're
doing the same thing still because we're
not chapter 3 is not just learning. It
is combining learning and inference. So
we're taking what we got from chapter 2
and we're combining that with oh here's
what happens when we also update our
parameters. And those parameters are
just those pieces that help us explain
well how did we get this X from the Y,
right? how how is it that we should
arrive at this particular prediction
based on the observations that we
received and that's what those beta you
know the these different kinds of
symbols that we see um we see theta
regularly uh representing uh the theta
being like kind of like the zero with a
with a horizontal line running through
it um yeah and so so the parameters are
help what it's what helps to translate
the y that you receive into the X that
you you predict about the hidden state.
And it's really important because then
we can invert that and say, you know, as
we saw in these chapters, your model
should not only be able to receive
observations and update a new
prediction, but based on its current
prediction, it should be able to vice
versa be inverted and say, "Oh, well,
the here are the observations I expect."
You should be able to kind of run the
model backwards, so to speak. But in
both cases, you're using those same
parameters. that's what makes kind of
makes up your the the specificity of
your your model. So yeah, we we just
kind of go back and forth in the
expectation maximization first we get
our our estimate for the states and then
in step two given that new estimate of
the states what should my parameters be
and then we go back to step one given
those new parameters what should my and
a new observation what should the hidden
state be? So you you just kind of do
this back and forth like you get the
observation, you update your states,
after that you update your parameters,
rinse and repeat.
Yeah. Um let let's just look at figure
3.2 staying with this regression
situation and then we'll pull back to
the whole chapter. So here's
figure um 32 on page 51.
This is a graphical representation of
the basing network for the linear
regression. So we have inside the box is
kind of like inside the situation of the
map. So I is the index of the
observation variable Y. So it could be
like the student number in the classroom
if it was nonsequential data or it could
be like the time step in a sequential
data situation. Could be like ordered or
it could have a meaning or not.
X is the latent state which has an
upstream causal effect on that
associated Y. So latent state, you know,
true temperature in the room,
observation on the thermometer, true
food size, light observation in the food
sensor example. And then kind of outside
the box but parameters that influence
from the statistician's perspective the
generation of Y are the variance
estimators and the the kind of signal
and noise estimators which have
different variables and notation for
like a different families of
distributions but they're going to
correspond to basically like fitting the
central tendency of the data fitting it
well and fitting the variability of the
data.
Kobus,
I don't hear you. Kobus.
Okay.
Mark wrote, "Is inference making a
prediction and the same thing as
estimating? Can learning be seen as
updating the model and this be construed
as inference at a higher hierarchical
level?" Frasier says yes. So yeah, in a
hierarchical model inference at one
layer could be like at a slower tick or
slower time scale and represent learning
at the
nested model layer. But right now we're
just looking at a one layer model and
separating out these two phases. And
then there's different ways that they
could be that the different um variables
could be set. Like parameters could be
set via fiat. If you're interested in
just generating synthetic data from a
given variability pattern, you might
just learn by fiat and just say, "Okay,
we're just going to assume that the
variables look like this." Or like
Andrew mentioned with expectation
maximization. That's kind of like a a
zigzag
two-step engine um joint optimization
for a given data set. what linear
regression should we fit over that data
set and that's done iteratively through
tweaking a line and then seeing how they
line up with the observations.
Okay.
Yes, good good comments in the chat. So
that's this basing graph. Let's just
look at all the the topics that are
going to come into play.
Okay,
where to begin? where where where does
this where's the doorway of this um
hidden state inference is where we left
off and focused on in chapter 2. So that
just said you already know the
relationship between the temperature in
the room and the thermometer reading or
the intensity of the light that you
observe and the true food underlying or
whatever it happens to be like you
already have the trained LLM on your
computer. you already have the trained
linear regression on your computer and
you're just going to either use it in
like a um observation mapping to best
estimates of unobserved states or you're
going to use it in the other direction
like going from some unobserved states
which you can set arbitrarily or from
some other process generate new pseudo
observations like making a synthetic
data set that's hidden state inference
and section 3.4
which we're going to probably do next
week is going to like pull back the hood
and be like this is a huge family of
models. This is not just like toy y= mx
plusb
linear regression models like the linear
Gaussian system that all of this is
discussed without loss of generality
about is an enormous category of models
that includes everything from like
1900's era classical statistics to the
kinds of statistical methods that you'd
see in the software packages for Python
or R
to machine learning to even sort of
almost um just a variety of other
machine learning related or fundamental
concepts and methods. So that's that's
going to come up in the next week
probably. It's just like when we're
talking about hidden state inference,
we're going to return to like y= mx
plusb and linear regression of a
Gaussian
a lot with like a mean and a variance.
However, there are are it's a much
broader category of models and
especially like size.
So, you might hit secondary
considerations like related to
computational resources or computational
complexity and um model pathologies and
data normalization and like a million
other things that data scientists will
be familiar with. But just in terms of
talking about the formalisms,
we're going to be able to keep talking
about linear regression while really
talking about quite a general category
of statistical models. So that's this
bottom part.
Um
in chapter 3, we're going to do not just
that hidden state inference like that
quick real time here comes a temperature
reading. What's the most likely
temperature in the room?
We're going to pull back to this
parameter estimization, parameter
estimation. So, how do we fit the
parameters that map between unobserved
and observed states like the A matrix or
whatever it may be? And in again next
week, we'll look at expectation
maximization as a way to basically go
back and forth optimizing incrementally
doing um parameter learning and hidden
state inference and like jointly
optimizing that to a satisfying
conclusion
as a way to go from observations
to parameter estimates.
So now staying with just parameter
estimation. So there's going to be
multiple ways of the multiple hows for
how we do parameter estimation. But for
now we can just say that from a given
set of observations were able to fit the
best relationship possible.
There are um two
settings
that it branches into from this
parameter estimation and that's whether
you're going to treat the parameter as
like a singular fixed value to be
determined
or itself a distribution over another
parameter.
So that corresponds essentially to the
difference between classical parametric
statistics on the deterministic branch
or frequentism
and full probabilistic basian linear
regression like methods where even your
parameter values like your beta is drawn
from a distribution of possible betas.
So you think I think the relationship
between height and weight is like a
slope of 7.
The frequentist approach to kind of
unpack that would be like I think it's 7
because in this data set I observed that
the best single line had a slope of 7.
So the relationship between height and
weight is 7 and there's some noise
around that sample to sample but the
relationship is truly 7.
And that's the best answer to that
question. The probabilistic approach
would be like okay before I looked at
the data set I believed that the that it
was that the relationship was 08 plus or
minus 0.1 like I had a belief
distribution about that regression slope
parameter
and then I did get a best fitting line
for a given finite data set but that
finite data set is just a realization of
a process that I could have resampled
and gotten differently.
And so each of those regressions, the
best fitting regression lines that we
get for a given finite draw of like, you
know, seven children from the classroom
or five thermometer points, we kind of
want to like talk about what's the
distribution of resampling heavily over
possible instantiations of that data
set. kind of like a population versus a
sample uh mean or variance.
Um now in the extreme case this can be
done fully non-parametrically
which is to say like with a bootstrap
where you have a given data set of 100
data points and you sample like all
combinations of 99 data points
and then you get a sort of cloud of
regression estimates
and then you can still say something
like yes we have a tight estimate around
or a loose estimate if it was like a
more variable data set. So those are
ways where you don't have to specify
distribution and you basically just do
like intra data set shuffling to
estimate how robust your regression
slope is. It doesn't require you to
specify distribution at all. However,
the basian approach which is what gets
leaned into heavily in this book and
field is where you explicitly know
whether you're treating a parameter as
kind of like the buck stops here. I'm
just trying to fit this with a maximum
likelihood estimate on this like higher
order parameter.
But that higher order parameter could be
a prior distribution over some other
parameter.
So it's like okay I I I went into the
situation believing that the height
weight regression correlation was 08
plus or minus 0.1 and then this data set
updated me to 7. So that's my posterior
belief. But why did I believe8 plus or -
1? Was it8
plus or minus 001 plus or minus.1 plus
or -01? And then even if I went to that
next level, why why was it plus or minus
001? Was it plus or minus 0.01 plus or
minus 0.001? And the point is not that
there's like a right number of levels to
go into that hierarchical modeling. It's
that you know when you're doing it and
when you're treating a parameter as kind
of like a spike and just a frequentist
like way to just fit the best value
given a priori beliefs or empirical
results which is called parametric
empirical base
and for which parameters you're treating
them fully probabilistically
which opens up all these avenues in
terms of interpretability and like
computational unification of different
processes.
So then on the deterministic branch we
revisit gradient descent in this
classical frequentist setting
as a way of achieving maximum likelihood
estimation which is basically explaining
the data best. And we hear a lot about
like bounding or minimizing surprise,
but minimizing surprise on the next data
point coming in is like the same thing
as maximizing the evidence for the next
data point coming in. It just turns out,
which we're going to explore in the free
energy sections, that there's a bound on
surprise in a way that you don't have a
bound on maximum likelihood.
And we'll we'll we'll talk about like
why and how that is. So being minimally
surprised is being is getting max is
having the most maximally informed model
and having the data point come in at the
center of the curve for where you have
the best fitting model already. Um 31
and 32 are going to slightly bifurcate
into the setting where we're doing
linear regression or multiple linear
regression and that's going to get
discussed in the context of like a
design matrix.
So instead of just having one
thermometer and one room, you could
imagine like a situation where you have
10 thermometers in 10 separate rooms. At
that point, doing the 10 regressions
together would just be kind of like a
convenience way to parallelize the
operations perhaps, but there's like no
relationship between each of these
rooms. Or you could have a situation
where you have 10 thermometers in the
same room, so the observations might be
heavily collinear.
Or you could have five from one room and
five from another room. So there's all
these different kinds of like linear
regression setups, which is a topic
that's also heavily explored in the SPM
textbook and software package is like
making these very very large design
matrices
that are ways to encode whole
experimental setups and configurations
into these matrices.
And then some of the linear algebra it
just it's mindboggling
like colliding uh you know thousands of
columns on this matrix that's very wide
and then uh thousands of
rows with just a few columns and somehow
these two matrices get crunched together
in a certain way and the output just is
tilted and the dimensions line up a
certain way and you get a certain shape
output. and it's like what you're
looking for.
Um
that's this multiple and single linear
regression section
and all of this is about getting
familiar with how do you fit the best
parameters
given a data set. So this is a lot like
standard frequentist statistics and then
this 3.3 is going to be like but also
there's this fully basian way to do this
where given a certain estimation method
which is going to get unpacked and
brought into the variational setting in
chapter uh four
you could have a belief distribution
over model parameters.
So just like inference was based upon a
prior distribution of beliefs around
hidden states mapping to observations
we're going to have another basian
process of learning which is going to do
parameter belief updating
but not of how big was that food
particle given that light intensity
which was like the real-time sensory or
perceptual inference but now
what should the parameter be mapping
food size to light intensity
given my priors and the observations
I've seen mapping them.
So, it's a similar regression
um situation
and it's kind of like
uh I don't know exactly like a bicycle
or two wheels a wheelbarrow or something
where a lot of these methods are going
to be um amenable to a frequentist
approach as well as a basing approach as
well as often a non-parametric approach.
So that is something that also the SPM
textbook does really well is for the
given statistical challenge sometimes
even in the same chapter or in separate
chapters show frequentist basian and
nonparametric statistical approaches and
so that helps you separate out like what
is the fundamental essence of this
statistical task from what are multiple
ways to do this different task.
And for a given data set or a given um
requirements of like interpretability or
methods that you must or cannot use or
computational complexity scaling all
these other features come into play. But
this is just talking about at the level
of like there's multiple ways to fit
even a linear regression. Remembering
though this is quite a broad family.
There's multiple ways to do the
inference given the trained model and
there's multiple ways to update and
train the model aka learn it and
sometimes you're just given the learning
problem as already solved and you're
just running the crank and doing the
forward inference.
Chapter 3 is saying, "Okay, but we're
also going to consider how those
parameters came to be, and they could
come to be in this frequentist like
approach,
which also can have gradient
descent-like methods.
And then chapter 4 is going to go into
gradient descent, variational basian
methods by way of doing learning and
inference as a unified process in this
basian linear regression setting.
Okay. Anyone want to make a like add a
point that that wasn't
kind of brought up in overview or
another question or thought
Va
>> I have a question. Um can I generalize
um that learning is parameter estimation
and those are the deterministic
parameters and inference is hidden state
estimation and those are probabilistic
parameters
which um
um tell me which model I have to use. Is
this correct
>> Andrew? go for it.
>> Um yeah, I just to answer that question.
Um yes uh yes to both questions with the
caveat that um the the way that you know
similarly in chapter 2 we were
introduced to inference by mainly
focusing on at first these deterministic
linear equations which is really just
didactic to help us see a a very simple
version of this uh before jumping to the
probabilistic framework. So here to
answer your question um yes for
inference we have now moved into like a
probabilistic kind of setting using
basis framework. Uh however as Daniel
mentioned we can do the same thing for
parameters. So you could uh estimate
your parameters in a linear or
deterministic fashion. Um but ultimately
through this textbook and by the end of
chapter 3 we will uh we can end up doing
the same thing. We can use
probabilities. So like Daniel was
saying, you could have an entire
distribution over potential predictions
of what a parameter should be. Just as
an inference, you could do the same
thing for what the hidden state as uh
prediction should be. I hope that's
helpful.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And just to add one piece
there, you you could do this parameter
estimation
through frequentist means like fitting
the least squares. Um like fitting the
sum of squares of a regression is always
going to result in the same estimates
for a given data set because it just
take it's just saying which line is
going to minimize the all of the
differentials
squared. They're squared sum. That's the
L2 norm or the least sum of squares.
That's a smooth or a convex optimization
problem. It always reaches the same end
point. So that's a deterministic way to
do parameter estimation. You also could
do probabilistic
prior driven
estimation of that linear regression.
It's a little confusing because
deterministic still could be a noisy
process. So like that example of of the
height and the weight having a 7
correlation that still means every
person walking through the door is a
stochastic process or a probabilistic
process. So you can still make your best
prediction but there's still
variability. So deterministic doesn't
mean kind of like crystallin or
um onetoone relationships amongst
components. Deterministic means that
regression slope, the parameter that
we're estimating is being treated like
it's a true fixed singular value without
an associated variability around that
estimate.
>> So the data is observed uh
the observed the data is available.
That's that is what I wanted to say. So
you can you apply the frequentist model
if not I choose the probabilistic model
in learning uh how how the model learns.
>> I'm I'm
>> yes absolutely that's that's a great way
to put it. The frequentist just says why
wouldn't I just simply take the one best
line through the data I have all of the
data I have like
what else would we be looking for
whereas the basian sees the data as a
draw from like a deeper generative
process and so we kind of want like the
unobserved
aspects
but sometimes those are lined up because
in the end why would we like be fitting
better on a hallucinated um or at least
or better way to put it would be you
know abductively proposed distribution
of latent states and fail to explain
well on a given data set and that's like
the the space of like overfitting or
underfitting and generalization of data
sets and if all you need to do is
benchmark max on a data set you will not
do worse than the maximum likelihood
estimate it's right in the name but if
you want to have these features like
interpretability
Robustness to overgeneralization,
flexibility to configure different
priors, ability to handle in a unified
computational like free energy
minimization driven inference setting,
then you you have to play over in the
fully probabilistic side.
>> Got it. Thank you.
>> Yeah, but a very good question. And
again, it's like it says deterministic,
which has every feel of being like
it somehow is is locking the the
relationship between height and weight,
but that would still be just
conversationally called like random or
noisy or variable.
It's still has a um you know, or like
like a roulette wheel.
Like every turn is still going to people
are still going to be surprised at the
outcome to some extent of every single
turn.
But it's a fixed unchanging actual
determined relationship
with how many of those numbers are on
the wheel.
Why is the basian approach more
interpretable?
Um that's a great question.
I'll I'll point to uh this paper. I'll
put this in the um notes. So this is one
one good resource on it by Alvarosen at
all. Um one of the short ways to kind of
think about the interpretability of the
basine approach is when you have this
probability distribution over regression
parameters. The modeler can go in being
explicit about their beliefs.
Whereas a frequentist implicitly has
like a flat distribution over regression
slopes and they pick simply the single
best performing regression parameter.
Whereas a probabilistic approach
could be like we're doing a meta
analysis on the effect of some food or
supplements and so we want to be
explicit whether we have strong beliefs
about effect size already or not. So
that could make us in a situation where
we have a lot of knowledge already and
we're dealing with a small data set to
not move our update our belief that
much. So it allows the experimentter to
be quite explicit about the exact shape
and intensity of their prior beliefs and
how much they're willing to update from
this new data set and test the
robustness of that updating and like
posterior belief against different
possible prior beliefs.
And another advantage is the uncertainty
variables. So the posterior belief
distribution is truly interpretable as a
belief distribution.
So that's like the concept of a basian
credible interval or like baze factor
which allows you to kind of give
statistical grounding to questions like
how much likelier is this model than
this model? Like how much likelier is
model A to be the case than model B? And
that can be tested in a very open-ended
way with basian models. But for
parametric models, it can only be
strictly tested in a nested setting.
And those uncertainty intervals have
direct interpretability of like we
believe it's 90 plus orus 2° with 95% of
the density and plus orus three with
this percentage of the density. Whereas
if you chat and type into an LLM, what's
your belief about the temperature in
this location with uncertainty
estimates,
it may output something that's like
directionally or qualitatively valid.
Like it might say, I think it's 90 plus
or minus two. But that string of tokens
was reached through turning the wheel
forward inference and kind of like
emulating in a really bizarre though
incredible way
what looks to be a probabilistic model
but it's not actually instantiating a
model. So there is interpretation to be
sought for in for example asking an LLM
a 100 times what do you think the GPS
coordinate of this city is and getting a
posterior distribution of its beliefs
using like structured outputs like kind
of reading the tea leaves with the
latent space of the LLM.
But the basian posteriors on their face
have a direct interpretability
and that confidence interval could be
under or over inflated. So it's not a
guarantee that that it is a model that
is adequate or best. But in a calibrated
model setting which is what we aim to
have then we have like a increased
interoperability and direct
interpretability of the parameters.
Whereas in these large hyperparametric
models like um with billions of
parameters like a language model there's
this whole art and science of
interpretability studies where they need
to take the billions of parameters and
then look for like the ien activation
across these layers and then correlate
that to this embedding distance and it's
like there's all of these
transformational steps
to go from parameters that themselves
are kind of subsemantic like the
activation probabilities of a given node
or a weight between two nodes in a
neural network and kind of regenerate a
meaningful
layer of interpretation.
Whereas part of the um direction and
advantage of small basian graphical
models
is the nodes that you're working with
and the nodes that are having inference
and learning happen on them are quite
explicitly like what you think they are.
You could have a horrendously bizarre
model that doesn't, you know, map
doesn't fit the territory all that kind
of like structure learning secondary
considerations,
but just like in the linear regression
um basian setting
like these estimates are kind of what
you think they are. It's not like a
neural network with billions of
parameters that interpolated this
distribution.
And then we're taking a secondary step
of like looking at summary statistics of
the parameters that were actually
learned like the neural network weights,
but we're just focusing our inference
and interpretation and design on the
exact same artifact.
Okay.
Goma. We'll we'll move up these and
we'll improve them in the questions
section.
I'm a little confused about frequentist
versus basian. Okay. So that's this this
branch right here.
Yeah. Frequentist is class classical
probabilistic.
Both are probabilistic in nature. Yes.
So both both the frequentist and the
basian regression they're going to be
trying to draw a line through the same
data set we've given it one agent is
going to do frequentist model one agent
is going to do a basian linear
regression so both are fitting a process
that for all intents and purposes can be
called probabilistic like the
relationship between height and weight
for this given data set or between light
intensity and food particle size for
this given data set. However, notice
that it says parameter is not a random
variable. The frequentist treats the
parameter as a spike variable which is
the best fitting like maximum likelihood
estimate
of the regression coefficient reached
through le squares regression
deterministically reached from the data
set and a single parameter with no
uncertainty about it. But it's used in a
process that at the sort of primary
level like the height weight mapping you
could say given this person's height do
I know their um weight with a 5%
variance or with like a 30% variance. So
just like conversationally in broad
picture we're talking about a
probabilistic or a statistical setting
but this fork is whether we're going to
treat that regression parameter
as something like the experimental
design is treated as fixed for a given
data set. Rarely would somebody even a
basian say like I'm 90% sure I did this
on this treatment and this on this
treatment. Like they're not trying to
learn over that variable. They're just
saying we have infinite we it's it's
deterministic which group we assigned
each sample from
Frasier. Um okay. Okay. Could the value
of a basian approach lie in how it lends
itself to iteration over time? Yeah.
Absolutely. Absolutely. There's so many
advantages to how optimization happens
through time. So in in a deterministic
batch updating setting, think about
this. It's like as the data points come
in, are you going to do just like an
arbitrary rolling window of a maximum
likelihood of the last n? If so, how
many of n are you going to pick? Or are
you going to do batch full data set
reanalysis every single new data point
that comes in? Whereas in Basian, the
common filter is exactly a way to have a
principled approach to know how much
inertia should you have from your prior
beliefs and how much momentum are you
going to have introduced from new
observations coming in and treating that
balance as something that you could do
learning and inference over.
And you can do this online incrementally
data point by data point just carrying
summary statistics through time. That's
basically like basian mechanics um or an
application of it. Whereas the
frequentist is going to have some sort
of secondary issues with how they are
going to deal with new with data set of
different confidence levels or patchy
data or all these other issues.
Like if we have temperature data for the
first 15 minutes of every hour or you
know blinks in and out, we want to have
like an underlying probabilistic belief
that would kind of get more uncertain as
we're missing more and more data and
then get picks back up versus what do
you do when there's missing data in a
frequentist setting?
Well, you could interpolate it linearly,
but every single frequentist
interpolation and even the frequentist
prior, the uniform prior, which is by
the way not unbiased, it's just biased
uniformly.
Those are special cases of the basian
design space.
So maybe it's a totally adequate special
case in which point
the discussion is moved. But if you want
to have the the features
um and maybe you converge upon a uniform
prior as being the best prior but then
you at least know why you had had that.
Okay. Frasier wrote active inference is
a basian approach not a frequentist
approach. It just so happens it pays to
talk about the lineage of ideas and
parameter estimation at this stage.
Absolutely very important for even
people who have taken like statistics
courses
recently
to kind of rebrush up on how it's being
talked about and introduced, what
notation is being used in this book and
again to separate out like the broader
idea of variability
from these different hows and wise and
what's of
inference and learning. In chapter 2, we
just looked at inference, just the
real-time inference from the learned
parameters. So, this question didn't
even come up. But again, that was a
probabilistic setting. In chapter 2, we
were determining probabilistically or in
a statistical setting the relationship
between the food size and the light
intensity.
But now we're peeling back to whether
that parameter of the model is learned
in a frequentist fashion kind of bean
counting fashion or being distribution
modeling as it were.
Okay. Andrew wrote,
"Yes, this is kind of like the the
basian epistemology
topic and about like there's a whole
story and and um area to explore about
for example um logical positivism.
the notion of making expressive positive
claims and incrementally accumulating
justified true beliefs as propositional
claims. And falsificationism,
which is like the idea that rather than
stating and accumulating positive claims
that we state hypothesis and then we
falsify or disfavor certain hypothesis
and we never show positively but we
relatively down
um rank alternatives which is like the
rejection of the null hypothesis idea
like science disproves, science doesn't
prove that kind of stuff. And then how
those ideas of like positive and
negative epistemologies
get revisited within a wholly
probabilistic
basian epistemology in terms of belief
updating. And then the pragmatic turn or
pragmatism
kind of like leans into that and it's
like yes it's belief updating and that's
including
the modeler or the scientist's ability
to acquire evidence and their
self-evidencing
and habits and preferences and priors
and biases and their engagements and
causal interventions in the world. not
just the optimal passive basian
spectator but the active engaged
participant
and then how that relates to these kind
of
18 to 1900s
ideas of of positive and negative
knowing.
Okay.
Mark wrote, "Difference and advantage of
Beijing methods is the use of prior and
handling of uncertainty variability
data." Yeah, I think those are probably
the two biggest areas. Explicit use of
prior
other than the uniform prior which is
implicitly used in frequentism and the
handling of uncertainty in terms of like
we have an explicit uncertainty
parameter.
So
um we can ask about how much of a given
distribution's belief mass is like
within a certain interval.
The Basian Gazette.
Okay, let's Okay, so
Andrew.
Yeah, I'm just to say I I'll try to keep
this brief and I'll cut myself off if
it's too long. Uh but uh I'm I'm just
trying to think I like thinking of like
everyday examples of trying to like
explain these things. And so um with a
kind of deterministic versus
probabilistic aspect like like should
you treat [clears throat] a parameter as
a fixed deterministic thing that you
estimate or should it be like more of a
probab probabilistic sort of thing? One
way of thinking about this sort of is to
think of it as like, you know, you're
teaching a student math. And in the
deterministic sense, the the student has
their own understanding of how math
works and how they should do a homework
problem. And so if you say, "Hey, how
did you you know, how confident do you
feel about this particular answer you
arrived at? Do you feel sure of it?" The
student will always say yes because it's
deterministic. like based on their
understanding of the math, we went from,
you know, they observed the problem.
That's their observation. They ran their
model, they arrived at the answer to the
homework problem. There's no concern
about uncertainty. There's no concern
about, oh, my model might be wrong. I
might need to inspect my model. Um,
things like that. Uh, alternatively, if
we treat it as more probabilistic, it
recognizes that it would be a student
who recognizes like, oh, my
understanding might not always be
exactly right. It might be something I
need to update. It might be something
that I need to reflect on how certain I
am. And then we'll see later in the
textbook like uh whenever it comes to
things like action, it'll also help
provide us with an understanding of how
we should act. Like whenever someone
goes out, they recognize they're
uncertain about something and so they go
out of their way to find more
information or we might call like an
epistemic drive. um they can do that
because they acknowledge in their own
model, oh I have a lot of uncertainty in
this area or oh when I receive these
particular observations I feel pretty
confident but when I receive these other
ones I'm more uncertain. So it actually
allows for a lot more sort of detail and
recognizing where is the model weak how
can we kind of uh compare different
kinds of models between one another and
things like that.
Yeah, that's
Thank you. also basian networks a lot of
these questions like you will find so
many good references and examples
outside of the active inference
ecosystem slashfristen
um cytoverse
like just looking up some of these terms
in chapter 2 and three especially
which don't even engage with free energy
mechanics yet you'll find a lot and
feeling
good about two and three even at that
level of just like chapter 2 is just
real time running the crank forward fast
inference given the trained model you
know given the brain as it is doing that
real- time perception chapter three how
did the brain get to be how it is how do
you fit the parameters on the neural
network how do you fit the parameters on
the regression and then four is when
we're actually going to head into
variational inference as an estimation
method
and it helps to increment up this way.
It's not the only way to go through this
material. There's not a only way even
for for a textbook level material but
like Sanjie has made a good path and
clearly thought about it well because a
huge amount of like especially the
philosophy of science and the broader
map territory
zone.
You realize that the variational
inference estimation method is like a
cgraphy
choice.
But you're already past the point of
doing modeling. And so it helps set
aside like what are the situational
aspects of doing statistics
and what are these kind of bigger
epistemological postures and ways of
talking about uncertainty in data
observed data and of unobserved
um systems.
And then like we're going to see and
argue for variational inference as a
flexible, interpretable, convenient,
powerful, scalable estimation method.
But that's not to say that in another
data set you're not going to be equally
or better suited by just doing a um
doing any of these other listed options.
Like these are all kind of like oneline
commands in Python and R and software
packages like principal component
analysis, K means clustering,
independent component or independent
contrast analysis,
sparse regression like lasso regression,
sensor fusion and signal processing.
All of these different methods, these
are all in the um signal processing
setting. We're still not really getting
to most explicitly talking about action
which will be dealt with in a very
satisfying um unified way by sampling or
selecting actions from belief
distributions about what I am going to
do next. That's how it's going to be
handled.
So that's not going to be different.
There's going to be the sort of added
situation of the causal efficacy of the
agent's action selection on the latent
generative process like the agent's
decision to turn on the air conditioner
as going to actually change possibly
even the mapping between observations
and generative latent states. But like
statistically these things may all be
useful in your toolkit more broadly. And
then it's it's um the art and the
science and the craft of which one where
and why. Frasier.
>> Yeah, you you sort of kind of got it
what I wanted to to reiterate. I just
wanted to make clear to people. Look,
everything that is on that slide at the
moment, figure 3.12 is an enormous
there's a huge number of things there
and you can take you can take a you know
several semesters college courses worth
of courses on on pretty much any one of
those things. It is not the case that
you have to understand all of this in
order to be able to understand the core
of active inference especially for later
on. So don't think that oh my god I have
to understand all these things now on
you know figure 3.12 in order to be able
to understand active inference. that's
very much not the case. He's in this
early part of the book, he's trying to
give you sort of a a preview or a um a
sense of where the general ideas are
coming from and and and the related
paradigms at issue. But it's not the
case that you have to master all of that
um to understand active inference. So I
think we have a question from Verona
now.
Uh maybe I simplify too much but can I
summarize and tell me if I I summarize
correctly. If parameters are known we
infer hidden states. If hidden states
are unknown and parameters are also
unknown, we need a method that combine
inference
and learning which motivates the um the
EM um um algorithm that comes later in
chapter 3. Is this correct? Did I
understand correctly?
>> Yes, perfect. If the parameters are
known, if we already have a trained
regression or we already have the
trained line uh neural network, all we
need to do is infer hidden states from
observations which is the recognition
model or generate pseudo observations
from latent states which is like the
generative direction.
And then if parameters are unknown,
we need to have a um ideally a joint
process of inference and learning and
their combination.
for example by doing em.
Okay, great great summary though. So Dan
wrote in the chat [clears throat]
you mentioned calibration. Can you
elaborate on how we'd perform
calibration in probabilistic and
deterministic path? Can we include the
process of calibration as part of the
learning or inference process or is
calibration separate? Um Andrew wrote
it's not in the canonical list of terms
but it's a relevant idea. Yes. Yes. I
was using it in a broader sense. So that
would be sort of at two layers. There's
the there's sort of the calibration
within a model like fitting but not
overfitting based upon um a loss
function within a model just like
fitting the data like calibrating the
parameter to the data on a first pass.
Then off the table, but in the modeler's
toolkit, you have a massive amount of um
modeler degrees of freedom related to
like should you hold out some data and
do like a training interval and a test
interval or do it out of sample
prediction or do you want to do like
k-fold cross validation where you have
um the data in cut up into five sections
and then you train all combinations of
four and then hold out on the fifth one.
And then how would you integrate those
five-fold cross validated results? Do
you take the average or are you going to
select the best one or are you going to
pick the a different train test split or
are are you going to subsample your data
or are you going to do there's a variety
of other ways that you could do like
inter or you going to generate a
synthetic data set and then test your
statistical model to do parameter
recovery or are you going to do
analytical closed form or empirical
statistical power sampling.
across different sample sizes to test
how identifiable different parameters
are under different situations.
Those are like some of the methods that
are used off the table that are
calibration methods as part of like the
broader statistical project
that relate to how you then interpret
the fit of a given model and visualizing
it. doing exploratory data analysis,
like just looking at some simple plots
and just be like, "Yeah, does this look
like it's, you know, a fast ball down
the middle or does it look like I'm on
some weird fringe edge case?" Sometimes
just from the statistical results alone,
it's hard to tell. Or like a linear
regression um
with low p value
and low r. So sometimes with a lot of um
data points you'll get a p value that's
statistically significant but that's
where you get things like statistically
significant isn't biologically
significant. So then you sort of
separate out just the purely statistical
calibration
and interpretation of of a probability
distribution from like how does it get
operationalized or what does it actually
mean or how is it communicated to the
stakeholder. That's in getting into the
way broader sense of calibration like
confidence calibration
if you're a statistical analyst and you
know does your model's 80% mean 80%
conversationally or does your model 80%
mean um is that within a smaller bounded
box
like um one statistical setting I was
looking on was um probability of an ant
colony having its mother colony on the
same field site. So we have a given
subset, but it's just one rectangle from
a bigger desert. So we say um given this
data set, there's a um 80% chance that
the mother is in this set. But then what
is the probability that it was a colony
that we didn't observe? that's going to
bring in some other modeling assumptions
or situations to test that aren't
necessarily within the observed data set
which was just the um genotypes of the
children and the parents.
So that's a broad broad topic with a lot
of uh kind of closed form and
statistical theory aspect. So how do
models not get overfit and how do how do
they get fit but not overfit in these
frequentist basian nonparametric
settings and then I think also pretty
importantly moving into the more
empirical data science and like AI
machine learning environment bigger
topics about like communicating models
and all that.
Okay,
I'll stop the recording and people can
stay for for a few minutes. So, thank
you.